welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Pixar's
Elemental not enough people are seeing
this movie but it has some of the best
animation details and art design of any
Pixar film I've ever seen so I'm gonna
break it down for some fun Easter eggs
you might have missed full disclosure my
wife works for Pixar and actually didn't
work on this movie but when I visited
the studio he did try to hide in the big
Luxo lamp so I could live there forever
and then security had to pull me out
with an apple picker it was a whole
thing but I just want to give you my
history with Pixar okay let's get
started the film opens as the Immigrant
story many of us were pleasantly
surprised to see a light in the fog
coming across the waves to element City
and embraced between Emperor's parents
Bernie and Cinder they're carrying the
blue flame of their people and Bernie's
suitcase is a charcoal grill arriving to
element City ahead of them is a hot air
balloon the third wave of them grits of
the cloud people having a slightly more
privileged path to citizenship Some
Cloud folks depart a blimp a crying baby
is leashed like a balloon about to float
away and then that blimp deflates to
sink down to the departure level where
it re-inflates and takes off director
Peter Stone was raised by Korean
immigrants and Bernie and Cinder store
worry with the Discrimination they face
they're forced to change their names
they live in zone neighborhoods they're
pushed to water down their spicy food is
rooted in his family's experience and
the experiences of many immigrant
families Tommy got to interview sewn
about his inspiration I went to this
ceremony they would ask me to do a
little speech about the Arts in the
Bronx in New York there I invited my
parents when I got got up on stage I saw
these faces and uh I broke to tears just
because I could see how much these folks
sacrificed to give my brother and I
alive Peterson actually voiced socks the
cat in light year he was a character
model for Russell and up Annie boys
Genki Lee and Spider-Man across the
spider-verse this Ellis Island style
Processing Center Honors the first wave
the water people the second wave the
Earth people and the third wave the
cloud people and Beyond fire people this
movie doesn't really draw overt
parallels between what race or ethnicity
those elements are meant to represent
like if they did either Earth or Cloud
people would have been brought over here
in Chains and there would have been
another element forced off their land
when the water people got there so you
know it's just best not to think about
it that hard as they house hunt in the
Garden District we see the Metro sign as
Au Fe those are the chemical symbols of
gold and iron and later the sign for
element City reads
a-h-a-l or a followed by H the hydrogen
atomic number of one and then aluminum
atomic number 13 so you get A113 the
recurring animation Easter egg for the
Cal Arts classroom many of these
animators went through for fire town the
symbols are s and C the chemical symbols
of sulfur and carbon elements associated
with fire and with burning these
periodic table of elements jokes are
something from sone's original pitch for
this movie when I was in school in
science class when I saw that table of
periodic elements I mean like I used to
make fun of it they look like an
apartment complex and all these little
windows and I would put like copper next
to helium but be careful helium's gassy
in the family shop the fireplace Bernie
Rings up some cold nuts while Ember
practices on some stacked boxes but over
time we see how Bernie slows down how
fast he can turn that wood into charcoal
I really thought he's gonna die in this
movie I got very nervous about Bernie
Ember meets the crushing kid Claude
outside who always first appears sitting
in a pot in this movie as the measure
water splashes over them Ember uses an
umbrella while claw just soaks it in on
her deliveries a couple's baby stroller
is another charcoal grill they feed the
baby lighter fluid baby formula Amber
gets caught behind a tree Yota log truck
and while Emperor is able to speedily
break her dad's delivery record it's
just a sign that she's more comfortable
outside the store than inside managing
the store which only seems to trigger
her anxiety meaning that she's probably
destined to leave this life Wade Ripple
flows into the flooded basement and I
just love that the first thing we see
from him are his gushing tears the
flooding caused his body to take a
muscular form and Ember is into it
Elemental is truly Pixar's most romantic
movie since Wally Ember chases Wade on
the Metro and in the darkness she sees a
glowing flame which is revealed to be
herself in the back of his head
foreshadowing that these two are
destined for each other and her light
reflected through him is going to be her
way through an uncertain world when she
goes in the main city we see a sign for
eat at Ralph's two cents which is a
tribute to the late Pixar director and
production designer Ralph Eggleston a
mentor to Peterson who would always give
his two cents about movies and bird
knocks into some bins marked Recycling
and upcycling those are the only two
options here they head into City Hall
where Wade appeals to Fern crouchwood
voiced by the soft-spoken comedian Joe
para on his desk there's a globe where
most of this world is green and water
colored but it has huge polar ice caps
because abundant plant life would mean
less carbon emissions and lower global
temperatures and mostly because there's
not a whole lot of fire people in this
world they're all clustered in the
southern continent representing the fire
Homeland and when this globe gets shoved
into Wade's face you can see that that
fire continent perfectly would fit in a
lake that we see within the green
continent showing that these societies
really do belong each other like jigsaw
puzzles and elements do mix and Amber
also shoves Fern's name placard so that
Wade's water magnifies the word ouch
Cyclone stadium is designed to look like
a giant tornado inside is a sign for
Flagstone tires and a strike from Cars a
tire company that sponsors those Racers
also on the scoreboard one of the score
is for passing gas Wade gets the crowd
going with a wave encouraging the player
Lutz we love you
feel the wind she needs to recall her
memories of going to these games with
her dad and having some empathy for
Amber and giving her a second chance
Wade tries to high five Ember but
they're afraid to touch as we see Wade
throughout this movie he becomes
increasingly sweaty and bubbly the
longer he and Ember spend time together
showing how his body chemistry is indeed
changing thank you to betterhelp for
sponsoring this video movies and TVs can
be great escapism but when it's time to
face things head on better help is here
to help better help is the world's
largest therapy service and it's 100
online with better help he can tap into
a network of over 30 000 licensed and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues to get
started just answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's
right for you after that talk to your
therapist however you feel comfortable
whether it's via text chat phone or
video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge Better
Health gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom pick for you
with scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com Slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy when they take the hot air
balloon over the city the lights from
the flaps of the tarp make a flower on
the ground below setting up ember's
ultimate wish in this movie to witness
the rare vivisteria flower Amber says
Garden Central Station flooded so she
missed a chance to see it showing how
the city has infrastructural flooding
issues that they never address because
they think it only negatively impacts
one element group but really it's making
their whole city a problem they just
don't care Amber joins Wade on a date to
tide and Prejudice the posters at the
theater include the good element anatu
Pizza Zone's past Pixar film that he
directed the good dinosaur Way taste
tests the coal nuts nearly boils to
death but watering him down gets in band
from the shop we dissolve from his
hilarious Polaroid on the banned list to
the sunset plunging into the ocean
Horizon representing the contact of Fire
and Water happening between these
characters on this beach Amber confesses
that she feels like a bad daughter and I
just love how the animators show her
Flames shrinking and smooshing and dying
out Amber actress Leah Lewis talked
about this in her interview with Tommy
but to see it visually after they've
animated it I was like hmm I didn't
realize how elegant she was in the way
that she moves and just so Swift and
then when she's angry like she's huge
and then like when she's quite dim and
really vulnerable like she's just like
you can barely even see her fire she's
just like two little eyes when ember's
mother follows her to Wade's apartment
there is a boat in the canal behind them
with a rocket ship on the top this
movie's Pizza Planet truck Easter egg
that you actually get a better look at
in concept art Wade's mother's voice by
Catherine O'Hara thus some of these
vocalizations sound a bit like Myra Rose
David Wade's weepy family also includes
his little sibling Lake and girlfriend
Ghibli her name a reference to Japanese
animation Powerhouse Studio Ghibli that
inspires many of the animators at Pixar
when Lake actor Kai Ava Hauser announced
their cast in his Pixar's first
non-binary character many responded with
the sad but true clip from the other two
globby that's right globby will be the
hunted Buddy's first ever openly queer
character
this goo is homosexual the goo is
homosexual incredible during dinner Wade
seasons is food with peppers
maybe he's grown a tolerance for more
seasoning
sucked into one of these as a kid in the
background is a fire alarm just little
detail showing this town's history with
fire phobia also there's a poster for
join the space club with a planet with
tentacles because Pixar puts in every
movie and not the next coming movie in
this case it's a nod to Pixar's next
release of elio a trailer for which just
came out Wade manages to win The Crying
Game with Ember by simply professing his
honest feelings for her but when they're
about to hug they stop awkwardly and
then Wade's cousin smacks him in the
butt with a pool noodle forcing some
water to bulge out his front side I mean
we know what that is but then in the
scene with ember's Mom Wade uses his
watery body to magnify ember's light to
ignite the incense just really clever
story design here showing how true love
is something where both Partners play a
role synthesizing something new from
each other that should logically be
impossible Wade swims Ember to the
Underwater Museum to see the vivisteria
in a bubble and I don't care how sweet
this is this was an insanely risky thing
to do and I was terrified for her the
entire time but it is another example of
how these elements mixing and working
together makes the impossible possible
the vivisteria even seems to react
specifically to ember's light suggesting
they needed her too and Wade and Ember
finally touch hands and it's just a
peaceful and relaxing simmer like a
Jacuzzi or Boiling Pot over a stove
making dinner and I'm just amazed at how
these story artists could get us so
afraid of Fire and Water mixing just for
Midas house Steam and bubbling water can
be one of the coziest things it feels so
right but Amber's taken out of it but
remembering her dad and we hear this
Neon
that sound is the sound of the fireplace
sign when she snaps in and out of the
moment Wade crashes the Lumen family's
reopening party and as Ember rejects
Wade we cut to the tempered glass of the
dam breaking which causes the flash
flood that again only affects fire town
this District it's a tragically common
thing in low-income communities they're
often particularly vulnerable to
flooding and the rest of the city just
doesn't care Ember rushes to save the
blue flame in the flooding shop Wade
arrives and he saves that flame in a
lantern but they're trapped and where
this was their mom's romance reading
room the place where it was confirmed
that they were meant for each other Wade
hugs her and he expedites his
evaporation and then we all turn into
weepy water people but Ember is able to
bring wade back by repeating that Crying
Game bits from before butterfly
windshield wipers half a butterfly old
man on his deathbed remembers the
summary fell in love and everything's
they got okay the film ends with Ember
and Wade leading so that she can go to
art school but before she steps on that
boat ramp she turns and offers her
father the box so the big bow the
gesture of Honor that his father never
turned to him when he left this is
really just a sad aspect of many
immigrant stories how immigrants will
leave behind parents who end up
disowning them and shun them for leaving
when really those immigrants are just
trying to give their own kids a better
life and that's something carried on by
first and second generation kids of the
immigrants they always have to remember
that sacrifice and they're often
pressured to find a way to repay that to
their parents and now Ember realizes she
is benefiting from that sacrifice gives
her father the connection that he
forever longed for and the final shot of
the movie Mirrors Bernie's first step
off the ramp into element City now Ember
takes her first step onto it hopefully
the positive word of mouth in this movie
gets more people to see it because I
loved it so much subscribe to new
Rockstar subscribe to the Deep dive And
subscribe to the break room and it can
support our Network programming some
merch like this Indie I love you shirt
at nerdrive.shop follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at eavos follow the new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you